إنه مجرد تقدم طوال
الليل حيث
كنا نعيش على شاشة التلفزيون نتحدث عن
هذا كما حدث حيث
بدت الأمور جيدة جدًا بالنسبة
للحملة الرابحة خاصة في
الغرب الأوسط بنسلفانيا إلى الغرب الأوسط
نيفادا أيضًا ،
لذا فنحن ننتظر التصويت لصالح  تعال في
الساعة 1 صباحًا
2 صباحًا
905 صباحًا وقد شاهدته للتو
وتحدثنا عن التقدم على مدار
الساعات العديدة الماضية ،
التقدم في تقدم ميشيغان
الذي قد يحدث في
ولاية بنسلفانيا ، هناك سبب لذلك
يفسر
لذا انظر إلى أفضل طريقة  افعل هذا ، دعني
أوقف تشغيل هذا لثانية ،
أريد أن أفتح حالة أوهايو ،
لقد فعلنا ذلك عدة مرات
وأعتقد أن هذا هو أفضل
عرض توضيحي لأنه بالنسبة لكثير من
الأشخاص الذين كانوا ينتبهون في وقت مبكر
من الليل
كانوا ينظرون إلى أوهايو وكانوا
ينظرون إلى الإقبال في أوهايو نظروا
في ضواحي
أوهايو وكانوا يقولون بذاكرتي إلى عام
2016.
بدا أوهايو دونالد ترامب وكأنه
خلعه  خريطة حالة
التأرجح لقد صدمت من قبل المريخ في
ولاية أوهايو
وفي وقت مبكر من الليل حيث
تم حساب التصويت المبكر وإصداره من قبل أوهايو
، بدا الأمر وكأن هذا سيتحول إلى
اللون الأزرق ، ربما أتيحت له الفرصة للتحول  الأزرق ولكن
على الأقل
ضيقًا للغاية ، هذا ما
حدث
يبدو مألوفًا تمامًا كما
حدث في المرة الأخيرة في شمال كارولينا وكذلك
إلى حد ما رأيت قليلاً في
جورجيا إلى حد ما في فلوريدا
بشكل أساسي كان نوع التصويت الذي
كنت تحسبه عندما
تملي ما  كان هذا
سيبدو كما لو كان أوهايو
رأينا معكوسًا على
مدار الساعات العديدة الماضية
مع هذه الولايات مع ولاية ويسكونسن مع
ميشيغان في
الوقت الحالي ، لا تزال بنسلفانيا حمراء ولكن
بدأت في التحول أيضًا
لماذا قاموا بحساب
تصويت يوم الانتخابات  أول تصويت شخصي
أولاً أنه طوال
الليل في جميع أنحاء
البلاد من الشرق
إلى الغرب كان منحازًا إلى حد كبير للجمهوريين
وكان ذلك بالتصميم عمل الرئيس ترامب
بناءً على ذلك شخصيًا ، قاموا بتفجير
أهدافهم الشخصية في
جميع أنحاء البلاد تقريبًا ، ما بقي
جيدًا على عكس ما كان يحدث
في أوهايو ، فما بقي
هو التصويت المبكر كيف انحرفت الأصوات المبكرة إلى
الديمقراطية بشكل كبير من
أين أتت من سكان المناطق الحضرية إلى حد كبير
مراكز الضواحي إلى حد كبير ،
بمعنى آخر ،
المعاقل الديمقراطية في هاتين الولايتين
وما زلنا نراقب كما يحدث
في بنسلفانيا قبل ساعتين فقط ،
كانت بنسلفانيا حوالي
630.000 صوت.  لكنها
أقل بـ 80000 لكنها أقل بـ
80.000 وقد حدث ذلك في
غضون ساعة ولماذا يحدث ذلك
لأن بطاقات الاقتراع بالبريد تأتي في
أكثر من مليون بطاقة اقتراع بالبريد
معلقة في جزء كبير منها من
معقل ديمقراطي في جنوب شرق بنسلفانيا
معقل ديمقراطي في مقاطعة allgheny ،
لذا فإن هذا هو التقدم وهذا هو سبب
حدوث ذلك ، ولهذا السبب
بدت في بعض الأحيان باللون الأحمر ثم
انقلبت فجأة  ه في بعض الأحيان العكس بالعكس